il faut évidemment s'interdire de
généraliser et prétendre que tous les
coureurs cyclistes sont dopés mais en
enquêtant aujourd'hui dans la ville de
repos du tour de france
on s'aperçoit que l'on retrouve un
nombre inquiétant de médicaments
suspects dans l'environnement des hôtels
où séjournent certaines équipes olivier
caroff olivier galzi jean pierre bade
chaque matin les poubelles sont les
seules traces laissées par les coureurs
des poubelles qui en disent parfois long
sur ce que l'on ne voit jamais l'autre
visage du sport seringue perfusion
ampoules la pharmacie pour aller plus
vite sur les boîtes le nom des coureurs
et parmi ces boîtes parfois des produits
interdits comme ces de corticoïdes le
bain telle en 4 et le sait les stones
chrono dose les corticoïdes partie de la
grande famille des médicaments
anti-inflammatoires et puis ça peut être
dévoyé parce que ça permet de retirer
certaines douleurs on peut augmenter la
charge d'entraînement pour explication
nous avons ramené les poubelles à son
propriétaire
l'équipe italienne à 6 traduction latine
un esprit sain dans un corps sain
le médecin de l'équipe qui nous a
affirmé ne pas prescrire ces produits
n'a pas dans un premier temps reconnu sa
poubelle
peut-être que là la poubelle plus belle
et la plus belle eau à haute pression ni
l'habitude des choses parce qu'il y
avait des noms des coureurs de se
découvrir peut-être cours est utilisé
pour héros sort j'ai pas utiliser le
binntal année le spectacle est en soi
ils étaients soigneurs et j'ai pas voulu
dire quelle soigneur utilise parce que
en tradition du cyclisme
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs utilise
produits intramusculaire entre colère et
comme médecins nous on est toujours
agréable à utiliser mais je veux
promettre en soigneront l'équipe en
position ou le soigneur réapparaît sur
le devant de la scène les goûts vous des
coureurs
ces personnages que personne ne semble
contrôler même pas les médecins dans
cette poubelle c'est vrai les autres
produits ne sont pas interdits pourtant
les experts que nous avons contacté
affirme qu'il serait un complément
parfait pour le pays ou l'hormone de
croissance ces géants du dopage dont
tout le monde parle ici
mais que l'on ne voit jamais de le pays
ce médecin suisse veut bien en montrer
daniel blanc s'occupe entre autres de
richard virenque
la star de festina pour lui prescrire ce
produit dopant ne pose aucun problème de
conscience
à mon avis quelques fois on protégerait
plus un sportif me donnant qui peut
dépôts qui lui permet d'avoir un taux
d'hémoglobine normal que les vitres s de
s'épuiser d'être malade de faire des
infections à répétition que de ne rien
lui donner est long et d'un trucs
invraisemblables un discours
inacceptable pour bien des praticiens
médecins sens et un médecin raisonnable
qui connaît l'entraînement qui connut la
physiologie l'entraînement qui connaît
la programmation de l'entraînement
qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va demander
aux sportifs d'en faire un petit peu
moins pour récupérer naturellement si au
contraire ce médecin se met à lui donner
des produits pour masquer la fatigue qui
peut commencer à le gagner pour le faire
continuer à s'entraîner et à participer
à des compétitions malgré les signes
évidents de fatigue et d'insuffisance
variés pas voir se met ça est un
criminel
plusieurs cas de morts suspectes
d'anciens cyclistes sont attribués par
les scientifiques à la consommation de p
o